[Musique]
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos
l'émission politique qui décrypte chaque
semaine la campagne de la prochaine
présidentielle au sommaire l'abstention
après avoir atteint des records aux
dernières régionales c'est la grande
inconnue pour 2022 si d'ordinaire
l'élection présidentielle et celle qui
mobilise le plus le contexte social
actuel inquiète sur la volonté des
électeurs à aller voter alors quelles
solutions pour mobiliser les français le
vote à 16 ans le vote par internet le
vote obligatoire ou tout simplement
changer la manière de faire de la
politique aujourd'hui c'est le débat de
la semaine jacques de guillebon et
alexis poulain vous donneront ensuite un
avant-goût du monde d'après en livrant
chacun un éclairage sur un dossier qui
devrait occuper l'actualité politique
des prochains jours mais d'abord celle
actu des éditos alors que françois
hollande sort un livre qui tirent à
balles réelles sur son camp que jean luc
mélenchon a réaffirmé qu'il ne croyait
pas en l'union des gauches et qu'anne
hidalgo paraît une fantomatique
messieurs en 3 mots comment définiriez
vous ce début de campagne de la gauche
bonjour jacques bonjour avec 6 alors ce
début de campagne de la gauche bien j'ai
l'impression qu'il n'y a pas de campagne
de la gauche en réalité des petites
phrases le retour des zombies de la
politique françois hollande qui ressort
un livre affronter alors c'est pas
vraiment ce qu'il fait lorsqu'il a
choisi de ne pas se représenter devant
les français et puis des candidats qui
sont en train de regarder où ils vont
sans avoir vraiment de stratégie j'ai
l'impression oui je suis d'accord avec
vous que françois hollande vient de se
moquer de l'éclatement de la gauche
c'est assez paradoxal on voit ridicule
puisqu'il en est un des auteurs de cet
éclatement de la gauche et de cet
émiettement et oui cette gauche on peut
dire qu'elle est pour l'instant dans la
campagne en trois mois je dirais qu'elle
est hors sujet qu'elle est triste c'est
qu'elle est pleine de ressentiment il ya
des gauches alors après je crois qu'il
ya jean luc mélenchon qui tentent de
refaire une campagne façon 2017 à on
voit qu'il est dans le temps long il a
commencé bien avant les autres il n'est
pas d'ailleurs contesté dans son camp
puisque c'est le rucher vous à la france
et insoumise maintenant le là toute la
question autour de mélenchon c'est est
ce que la france insoumise peut se
transformer en union populaire ce qu'ils
souhaitent c'est à dire arriver agrégé
d'autres candidats ou à être d'avoir une
assise plus large à gauche lui même le
dit il n'y aura pas d'union à gauche ce
sera extrêmement compliqué là ça reste à
voir yannick jadot aussi qui fait une
campagne très calme qui regarde anne
hidalgo en chiens de faïence et qui
après avoir géré sandrine rousseau en
disant je n'ai de compte à rendre à
personne va essayer de faire une
campagne de social-démocrate et
récupérer ce qui reste sans doute un peu
du ps un peu de ma chronique déçu et
quelques écologistes qui vont aller avec
lui et puis on hidalgo bien l on l'a vu
à la mairie de paris avec olivier faure
qui d'ailleurs
n'ont pas la main mais presque mis une
baffe en dix ans personne ne souhaite
notre victoire mais voilà l'investiture
allez-y avec une affiche de campagne qui
ne dit rien en fait sur fond blanc avec
un demi-sourire on ne sait pas où elle
va pareil pas de programme pas de
stratégie non plus oui et on suppose
qu'elle est très heureuse d'avoir le
soutien de françois hollande aujourd'hui
est de faire gagner des points et va la
rendre encore plus sympathique dans
l'opinion je suppose mais ce qui est
drôle c'est que c'est sandrine rousseau
peut-être qui était le visage de la
gauche ou des gauches julie et peut-être
qu'elle avait raison là dessus c'était
la seule qui essayait de parler aux
mélenchonistes jusqu'au socialiste et
plusieurs choses qui essayait d'être le
point central et en asie alors incarné
parfaitement cette union gauche que ne
veulent pas d autre que veulent pas
mélenchon que ne veulent pas jadot
évidemment puisqu'ils ont chacun leur
parti à faire jouer alors c'est des
partis qui sont évidemment
microscopiques à ce que dit françois on
y parle de guerre picrocholine et
microscopiques mais c'est le fait de la
politique de françois hollande un deux
voire l'éclatement du parti socialiste
de voir la façon dont tous n y était et
c'est vrai que sandrine rousseau elle
avait ce nouveau visage aussi là on a
affaire à des dinosaures de la politique
qu'ils sont tous là depuis des années on
les connaît on sait ce qu'ils valent
avec des stratégique où finalement on a
l'impression qu'ils discutent déjà les
législatives et qu'il pense de toute
façon que c'est perdu pour le deuxième
tour en 2022 pour la présidentielle sauf
jean luc mélenchon qui lors de son
meeting arras a dit on peut être au
deuxième tour il y croit c'est la
méthode coué en disant il suffit d'aller
convaincre il faut un million de plus
sur les listes électorales on va en
parler alors 2e là je suis enthousiasmé
sur la candidature de jean luc revol et
l'enthousiasmé mais il faut l'être mais
c'était passionnant c'est que la gauche
à deux sujets qui doit elle a présenté
depuis longtemps et sur lesquels elle
devrait gagner aujourd'hui qui ont le
pouvoir d'achat mais à écologie qui sont
les sujets qui sont censés passionnés
des gens en tout cas l'écologie des
jeunes gens et on avait vu que les mères
aux écologie avait remporté les grandes
métropoles mais ce qui prouve les verts
avaient remporté les grandes métropoles
pardon ce qui prouve qu'il ya une vraie
scission entre ces grandes métropoles et
le reste du pays est en tout cas sur
cette question là mais sur le pouvoir
d'achat c'est encore plus étrange que ça
veut dire que les français ne font plus
confiance à la gauche avec ces méthodes
qu'on peut dire socialiste pour résoudre
ces problèmes de pouvoir d'achat alors
que pourtant il arrive avec des
propositions gigantesque de doubler le
salaire des professeurs d'augmenter le
smic si vous avez chèque énergie à tout
le monde non seulement la gauche devrait
gagner là dessus comme des français sont
inquiets de ça met une ambiance et
emmanuel macron qui continuent à
empocher les tâches et emmanuel macron
commence sa carrière politique à gauche
un il récupère les cendres du parti
socialiste et il finit à droite en
essayant de récupérer toute la social
démocratie centre d'entraînement il ya
eu un fils mais peut-être on verra mais
toujours est il que c'est vrai que sur
ces thèmes-là notamment l'écologie c'est
un thème qui est un cap tables en fête
par un parti politique tout le monde
maintenant se réclame de l'écologie
de l'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche
en passant par le centre tout le monde
est obligé d'avoir un discours sur
l'écologie donc c'est difficilement
capitalisables pour en faire
transformer ça envoie et puis pour le
pouvoir d'achat le problème c'est
qu'elles sont les solutions réalistes
quand anne hidalgo parle de doubler les
salaires des profs tout le monde sait
que c'est ridicule enfin cesser ces
louables mais comment le fait-on comment
finance-t-on une mesure telle que celle
ci et c'est bien tout le problème de la
gauche c'est d'avoir une vision réaliste
avec cette scission de la gauche de
gouvernement a incarné par françois
hollande en son temps manuel valls et
puis la gauche lui aussi qu'ils restent
là et en disant il faut concilier ces
deux là parce que l'utopie est
nécessaire si on veut faire voter les
gens c'est bien ça le problème quand on
est réaliste finalement de gauche on est
de droite alors pour être de gauche il
faut être au top est certain que je
rebondis là dessus ce qui est fascinant
c'est que cette gauche n'est toujours
pas compris qu'il fallait qu'elle parle
de sécurité et d'immigration aujourd'hui
elles sont par même pas de ce sujet dès
que la droite elle le laisse à la droite
de la droite en parle elle va lui taper
dessus en disant regardez politique
sécuritaire policière haine de
l'étranger et xénophobie mais à part
rené roussel qui peut être un début
timide de discours là dessus ça fait 20
ans 30 ans qu'elle en a pas parlé comme
si c'était quelque chose de ce don se
soucier pas les français mais qu'elle ne
pouvait pas couplées ça de manière
humaniste à sa manière elle avec son
discours sur le pouvoir d'achat c'est
très compliqué et et puis il ya ce
problème je crois aussi au delà des
zombies politiques comme françois
hollande et des partisans be le parti
socialiste aujourd'hui qui se réclament
de la gauche mais qui n'existent
quasiment plus alors ils ont des élus
certes ils essayent de sauver ce qui
reste à sauver mais en terme d'animation
du débat c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit
françois hollande dans son livre le
parti socialiste a disparu du débat il a
choisi de s'effacer face à la macro ni
triomphante et il n'a rien fait
finalement de ces cinq ans pour
reconstruire une social-démocratie à
gauche résultat on se retrouve avec cet
éclatement qui fait que ce sera sans
doute très difficile d'avoir un candidat
de gauche au deuxième tour oui on se
retrouve avec des candidats aujourd'hui
qu'ils vont avoir leurs signatures
d'élus puisqu'ils ont plein d'élus dans
ces parties là et aucun électeur et
inversement peut être d'autres candidats
qui aurait une masse d'électeurs mais
qui n'auront pas de signature donc c'est
un peu là
comment dire le cadre nature du cercle
aujourd'hui dans cette démocratie
place au débat de la semaine avec un
désintérêt de plus en plus prononcée des
français pour la politique et une
abstention record aux dernières
régionales en particulier chez les
jeunes 82% des 18-35 ans ne s'était pas
rendu aux urnes comment raviver la
flamme chez des électeurs faut-il revoir
en profondeur la politique ou chercher
des solutions du côté de la manière de
voter prendre en compte le vote blanc le
vote dès 16 ans le vote obligatoire ou
par correspondance bref nous ouvrons le
débat messieurs avec une première
question l'abstention s'explique-t-elle
avant tout par un ras le bol des
français à voter trop souvent par défaut
non je pense que l'abstention s'explique
par la structuration du pays aujourd'hui
on est dans un régime politique
présidentielle chacun sait depuis le
général de gaulle donc il se trouve que
tous les sept ans à la guerre tous les
cinq ans aujourd'hui il ya une sorte de
grande coupe du monde comme ça en france
qui s'appelle les présidentielles pour
lesquels tout le monde s'excite comme
nous en ce moment un an six mois avant
il ya des qualifications des matches de
poule et ensuite une fois que cette
élection a eu lieu les français s'en
désintéressent même aux législatives qui
ont lieu depuis le quinquennat ce qui
est une grave erreur à mon avis juste
après l'élection présidentielle les
français sont déjà beaucoup moins
nombreux à voter qu'ils sont allés aux
prises en cédant que cette cette
élection parce qu'on pensait sont
peut-être un peuple un peu monarchiste
dans l'âme qu'on se rentre tout le tous
les espoirs et le reste les intéresse
pas oui eh ben c'est exactement ça je
crois qu'il ya une infantilisation de
fête de la démocratie par la vème
république est encore accentuée par le
quinquennat en disant l'élection majeure
c'est la présidentielle et on y va un
peu pour jouer c'est un peu comme un
pari on va avoir son son cheval et puis
on va on va parier ou 100 barils de
lessive on va dire voilà on y va mais
quand on voit effectivement sur les
élections intermédiaires c'est une
catastrophe les records d'abstention
c'est les municipales c'est les
régionales c'est pourtant là que se font
la gestion de la commune la gestion de
la vie citoyenne de la vie en commun on
voit bien que les français se
désintéressent finalement d'être citoyen
or le droit de vote c'est important si
on n'utilise pas pourquoi l'avoir et on
a l'impression que c'est par un droit de
vote c'est un droit de jouer on va jouer
à l'élection présidentielle on va jouer
à la démocratie et derrière on a cinq
ans comme on vient de vivre avec ce
quinquennat macron ou bien finalement le
parlement est inexistant parce qu'on a
une assemblée de députés godillots
playmobil comme on les appelait qui ne
servent même pas à débattre qui sont là
pour être une caisse enregistreuse d'une
chambre d'enregistrement des décisions
par décret de l'exécutif et accentuer
encore alors la crise du commis de là on
a vraiment vu la caricature de la
cinquième mais je pense que oui à la
décharge des français il ya tout ce
qu'on leur a imposé depuis plusieurs
décennies c'est à dire qu'il ya deux
quinquennats évidemment donc il ya
quelqu'un comme vous le dites le le
parlement sur la présidence et il ya
plus de plus aucune autonomie du
parlement il ya l'union européenne dont
les français ont l'impression que c'est
elle qui décide a eu notre parlement
même si ce n'est pas tout à fait vrai
mais c'est en partie vrai plus qu'une
caisse enregistreuse décisions prises
prises à bruxelles et sachant qu aux
élections européennes on va voter pour
un tel nombre de députés qui n'est pas
grand chose sur le nombre de députés
européens donc la france n'aura assez
peu d'influencé ce sont les allemands
qui gagneront encore une fois il ya
salvia la fosse décentralisation qui a
été fait c'est à dire que les gens ne
savent pas à quoi servent les
communautés de communes non le
département les régions qui ont acquis
plein de compétences mais qui n'ont pas
le droit de lever des impôts enfin bref
y'a un le millefeuille administratif
comme on dit en france qui s'est
surajouté et le français a plus la pas
l'impression que plus personne plus
aucun élu n'a d'influencé après la crise
on aurait pu et peut-être son maire et
encore son maire est lui-même noyé dans
la communauté de communes qui va lui
dicter des ordres technocratique de nuit
jeu mais je crois que c'est on parlait
tout à l'heure de la question de comment
ré intéresser à la politique mais c'est
vrai que la politique est devenue une
gestion administrative technocratique de
la vie publique et c'est ça qui fait que
je pense qu'il ya un désintérêt total du
vote parce que on a vu les hommes et les
femmes politiques
interchangeable avec des discours vides
totalement creux aucun enjeu finalement
de civilisation où aucun enjeu de future
de construction d'un commun on est là
pour dire alors oui on va continuer les
réformes structurelles c'est l'europe
qui les demandent alors oui on va
continuer mais finalement avoir moins
d'argent parce que il faut faire moins
d'état regarder valérie pécresse dans la
course à la suppression d'emplois dans
la fonction publique elle passe de
150000 à 200000 comme ça d'un claquement
de doigts pourquoi pas un million tant
qu'à faire et donc c'est vraiment un
discours qui n'intéressent plus personne
je crois qu'on est dans un anachronisme
total et c'est ce qui fait en partie je
pense le succès d'eric zemmour auprès de
son public c'est parce que lui arrive
avec des grandes idées et pas du tout
des idées au quotidien sur le montant du
smic et pourtant c'est important sur la
fréquence des ter c'est vrai que c'était
lui il est là pour poser un cadre et
dire on doit aujourd'hui avoir un débat
d'idées qui vole un peu plus haut que ce
qu'on entend depuis depuis des lustres
par ces énarques formé entre bruxelles
et la city puisque c'est le problème et
même voir qu'on a l'impression que nos
hommes politiques la collection depuis
30 ans n'ont pas compris en quoi il
était à l'origine de cette grève
abstentions alors qu'on n'est pas une
énarque sur ce sujet en train
d'engueuler ses électeurs
les électeurs ne se sont pas déplacés
c'est pourquoi je les appelle au sursaut
tous ceux qui veulent exprimer leur
opposition à l'action de ce gouvernement
qui conduit le pays au chaos ont le
devoir de réagir si vous voulez que les
choses changent vous devez voter
si vous ne votez pas pour vos idées
votre voix ne porte plus oui et c'est
pas je pense en houspillant les
électeurs qu'on va les faire voter au
contraire il ya vraiment un refus d'auto
critique de la part de la classe
politique on le voit d'ailleurs ils ne
parlent que de gadgets le vote à
distance le vote par correspondance la
majorité à 16 ans trouver des façons de
faire le vote électronique etc c'est pas
ça qui va faire beau joueur surtout le
vote à 16 ans quand on vois pas je vous
interromps quand on voit que les jeunes
n'ont pas voté à 80 7 % aux régionales
elle vit 34 ans si on imagine que les
gens ne cédera en ont voté encore plus
leur faire remonter le vote va je vous
laisse le continuer mais n'ont donc donc
c'est pas parce qu'on va avoir des
gadgets techniques ou des façons de
voter plus facile le vote dans les ehpad
on en parlait la semaine dernière dans
le groupe korian qu'on va pousser les
gens à voter non ce qu'il faut c'est les
intéressés à la chose publique le aussi
de faire comprendre ce devoir citoyen
qu'est le vote parce que le lâcher ces
lâches et aussi le fait d'accepter de
faire partie de cette communauté alors
on peut avoir des grands débats sur la
laïcité sur l'école sur l'identité
française si on ne vote pas alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait dans ce pays il ya une
vraie question là dessus donc je pense
qu'à une éducation civique et qui est au
plus proche des gens c'est à dire au
niveau local qui est important quand on
voit les régionales et municipales c'est
inquiétant de voir qu'ils aient si peu
de personnes qui se déplacent et puis à
la question de la légitimité ensuite de
ces gens qui sortent des urnes avec si
peu de votants on le voit à l'assemblée
nationale regardez qui sont les gens qui
sont censés être des élus représentants
de la nation ils ne représentent rien et
en plus vous avez le problème en france
que si vous êtes ouvriers salariés
employés vous ne pouvez pas ou c'est
très difficile vous de vous présenter à
un mandat électif vous pouvez le faire
quand vous êtes en profession libérale
quand vous êtes issus des grands corps
d'état ou fonctionnaires
mais si vous êtes salarié essayez de
vous présenter un mandat vous allez voir
si vous allez retrouver votre emploi si
vous perdez s'il revient à l'élection
présidentielle est quand même des choses
qui peuvent nous rassurer je pense dans
l'est année c'est notamment si on se
penche sur la question américaine où
depuis 2004 sur tout 2008 et 2012 le
nombre de l'abstention a baissé parce
que sans doute quelqu'un comme barack
obama est venu stimuler les électeurs
mais peut-être donald trump ensuite
voyons de façon et on se regarde en
france nicolas sarkozy en 2007 avait
rien si je pense à lui tout seul à faire
chuter grandement l'abstention qui
avaient été au plus haut sous le
deuxième mandat de jacques chirac et qui
avait donc pu mener parce que le taux
était très bas jean marie le pen au
second tour donc on peut ne pas
désespérer et imaginer que si certains
candidats passionnant et qui parle au
foulard il va sortir deux de ces
primaires ou en tout cas de ses choix
qui se font actuellement et puisse y
avoir un sursaut démocratique français
les gens commencent à dire s'est il
faudra voir faudra sondés peut-être eric
zemmour vache va chercher dans
l'abstention ou pas du tout peut-être
qu'une sandrine rousseau aurait pu faire
la même chose peut-être que j'en ai
miguel ange on va y arriver je pense que
cela est aussi dû aux personnes et c'est
ça le d'ailleurs le fonctionnement
autant d'ailleurs des états unis que la
france ces régimes présidentiels et
c'est dû aussi à ça oui mais attention
un candidat c'est pas ensuite un
politique au pouvoir nicolas sarkozy qui
a déplacé les foules ensuite il avait
comme secrétaire général adjoint de
l'elysée jean castex on écoute jean
castex c'est si facile de dire vous en
avez l'habitude tout est la faute du
gouvernement
ça n'est pas le cas et vous le savez
bien c'est tout le monde qui est
interpellé par cette abstention y
compris des exécutifs locaux qui n'ont
pas su drainer a expliqué l'importante
cette élection évidemment évidemment
c'est une responsabilité collective
c'est une responsabilité collective et
nous devrons réagir collectivement
une responsabilité collective mais quand
on voit bien sur ce débat public quand
on voit aussi le refus d'autocritique de
dire pourquoi finalement nous n'allons
pas chercher les électeurs on a des
candidats qui ne font quasiment pas
campagne regarder cette campagne
présidentielle qui est entre deux on a
l'impression que personne ne veut y
aller ou très peu et le débat est là et
hélas les solutions proposées elles sont
finalement
davantage de problèmes proposé le vote à
16 ans on en parlait à l'instant qu'est
ce qui va faire qu'à saison à
s'intéresser davantage qu'ils aient 18
ans à la chose publique rien lancement
sera le corps électoral mais ça fera
encore baisser davantage d'attention
peut-être baisser la participation
le vote par correspondance
regardez l'imbroglio aux états unis
aujourd'hui vous avez 75% des électeurs
de donald trump et des républicains qui
pensent que le vote a été volé à cause
de ce vote par correspondance donc il
faut trouver les moyens d'encadrer un
vote à distance qui serait sûr et
incontestable ce qu'est ce que ça veut
dire le vote par correspondance va dire
qu'on suppose que le citoyen n'est pas
capable de se déplacer deux fois dans
l'année pour aller mettre un bulletin
dans l'urne à côté de chez lui c'est un
tragique en quinze ans ça veut dire que
ce serait juste un droit comme ça qu'on
peut exercer en appuyant sur un bouton
et sans avoir même ce ce mouvement-là de
déplacement et quant au moins de votes
blancs je pense que ce serait le 20 la
reconnaissance du vote blanc style
bonnes choses dans la première chose il
jouirait la pression se retrouve avec
une majorité de votes blancs ce sera
compliqué de trouver une légitimité mais
c'est déjà le cas mais c'est avec
l'appréhension qui met le pire je pense
reste en quoi cette cette campagne que
veut faire cyril hanouna doit se
déplacer en france pour un aller faire
voter les français s'ils y arrivent
bravo je sais pas si ça serait pour des
bonnes raisons que ce sera uniquement
parce que je crois c'est des spectateurs
sont dit que c'était drôle d'aller voter
mais qu'elle sera un rapport encore une
fois avec le local la citoyenneté de la
démocratie je pense que c'est la firme
hertz a fini de pousser
l'infantilisation et la politique
spectacle à son paroxysme je crois
justement c'est un des écueils cette
politique spectacle d'arriver à dire que
c'est un show c'est un catch on va voter
pour un candidat parce que finalement
c'est une idée évanescente non derrière
il y à des administrations un programme
une volonté un cap comme je le disais
donc je ne vois pas comment on va
intéresser les gens cette chose à part
peut-être pour la présidentielle parce
que c'est ce moment je finalement vont
jouer à voter on joue à la démocratie la
démocratie ce n'est pas ça et on voit
bien
les solutions elles sont compliqués
difficiles alors y en a une moi qui me
paraît intéressante c'est d'étaler le
vote pas seulement un dimanche pas
seulement un week-end mais comme le font
les anglo saxons pouvoir voter à la
sortie du bureau le soir et ça sur
plusieurs jours ça permettrait peut-être
d'avoir davantage de gens qui se
déplacera tient ce soir je peux y aller
j'ai pensé pouvoir
glisser mon bulletin dans l'urne
pourquoi ne pas organiser ça à condition
que ça n'influe pas sur le vote des
autres qui voteront ensuite et qui
seront déjà au courant bar j'ai senti
des dieux surkis influera on a déjà les
sondages qui influe bon sens ou sur le
sur le vote des gens en revanche on
pourrait évoquer aussi oui le vote
obligatoire qui a lieu dans d'autres
pays qui est contraire à la tradition
française où l'on reste libre de son
vote mais si on veut penser une vraie
démocratie si on pense que le peuple et
muret qui doit voter ce dont je peuvent
totalement sur tout le temps pourquoi
pas dans ce cas-là ne pas faire voter
chacun est en tout cas ça ça changerait
je pense considérablement les résultats
dans les yeux notamment que les jeunes
aillent voter que une bonne partie des
gens de la france périphérique ou de la
france des banlieues fin des gens moins
éduqués pour moins voté je pense que ça
changerait totalement les résultats et
on n'aurait pas une assemblée de des du
maquereau nice n'est sûr est élu avec 13
patients de l'essai du corps électoral à
l'oeuf toute la question du vote
populaire finalement à les faire voter
ceux qui ne votent pas ceux qui sont les
sans voix qui sont les oubliés de tous
les programmes de manière générale et
c'est vrai que faire voter tout le temps
on a parlé on n'a pas parlé du ricain du
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
mais en suisse son agitation il ya une
limite à ça c'est l'argent c'est à dire
qu'il ya tellement de votation que les
suisses en ont assez marre et que les
campagnes se font par l'argent et
aujourd'hui on a un ancien président de
la république qui avait fait appel aux
sondages qui se retrouvent devant la
justice parce que appel d'offres
beaucoup trop d'argent dépensé dans les
sondages je pense qu'aussi que la
démocratie sondagière atteint ses
limites et ce n'est pas animé le débat
public que faire des sondages à six mois
l'élection présidentielle
[Musique]
direction le monde d'après alexis poulin
et jacques de guillebon vous apportent
leur éclairage chaque semaine sur une
information qui pourrait faire
l'actualité politique de demain et cette
semaine c'est alexis poulain qui
commence alexis de quoi avez vous choisi
de parler
[Musique]
et bien cette semaine j'ai choisi de
parler du prolongement bien sûr dupas
sanitaire de la vote du vote pardon de
la loi de vigilance sanitaire avec une
assemblée vide à on parlait de
l'abstention devant les urnes on peut
parler de l'absentéisme parlementaire 75
voix ou 74 voix contre 73 qui font
passer finalement la possibilité d'avoir
recours au passé lithaire jusqu'en
juillet 2022 la loi qui passe à 135 voix
finalement pour dire qu'on est en état
d'urgence permanent cette loi de
vigilance sanitaire mois elle m'inquiète
au plus haut point depuis le début le
fait qu'elle soit encore allongée de
huit mois est encore plus inquiétant
parce que ça veut dire qu'on rentre dans
la société de la vigilance voulue par
macron à l'époque de du risque
terroriste mais attention on a juste le
risque terroriste le risque maintenant
du virus qu'elle risque on va ajouter
pour enfermer les gens dans une société
de la paranoïa totale du contrôle de
tous par tous je crois qu'il est temps
de dire stop et là encore voilà la
responsabilité des politiques qui ne se
déplace pas quand ils sont
parlementaires qui ne font pas
finalement un débat digne de ce nom par
rapport à une loin qui engagent notre
démocratie notre façon aussi de vivre en
société vers une société de la vie dans
ce que je refuse absolument vous savez
quoi je vais finir par me convaincre et
le vote de cette loi va finir par me
convaincre moi aussi je trouve ça
scandaleux à la manière dont ça a été
voté comme vous le dites avec très peu
de députés qu'ils soient déplacés alors
que ça aussi important que vous venez de
le dire et surtout voilà que le
gouvernement se donne sans autre forme
de procès la possibilité de perpétuer ce
se passe alors que pour l'instant la
situation sanitaire est au meilleur de
sa forme ce des renforts au plus bas
pour le nombre de cas et que ça semble
pas être l'urgence après que le
gouvernement ait les moyens d'intervenir
rapidement moi je reste disposé à ce que
ce soit le cas mais vous avez raison
cette société de
de vigilance et d'état d'urgence en
toute matière est insupportable
peut-être demain on aura un état
d'urgence climatique
là où au moindre moindre geste vous
serez contrôler et arrêter et là dessus
oui je trouve ça assez pénible surtout
que emmanuel macron se revendiquent de
ce terme de société de vigilance on a
l'impression d'être danger par des
voisins vigilants dans un village et
qu'il faut surveiller chacun son voisin
sas et c'est très énervant à la fin et
je vous rejoins presque dessus même si
sur le reste de la gestion de l'épidémie
j'ai fait d'accord avec vous voilà moi
j'ai choisi de parler d'un sujet qui
peut se rapprocher là dessus puisque ça
parle encore de législatives et de et de
corps de corps électoral la question qui
se pose aujourd'hui c'est à droite et
l'extrême droite qui va pouvoir se
présenter comme à la députation demain
vous avez vous savez que vous avez donc
le 3 quand aujourd'hui l aire marine le
pen eric zemmour qui pour l'instant
n'ont pas trouvé d'accord et qui font
chacun à peu près 15 % vont sheller ils
ont leur candidat habituel et naturel en
revanche sous marine le pen et le
reversement social comme on le sait ne
n'ont jamais eu beaucoup de députés on
est déjà parce qu'ils disposent pas de
réservoir de personnes assez crédible et
assez implanté chez eric zemmour c'est
encore pire puisqu'il n'a pas de faim si
jamais il est candidat on sait toujours
pas il n'a retiré aucun parti et donc il
n'a personne derrière lui alors je
trouve qu'il ya plein de tractations qui
ont lieu en ce moment pour essayer de se
partager ce qui pourrait être le gâteau
potentiel des candidats là bas qui
représente on va dire la bourgeoisie
traditionnelle plutôt catholique c'est à
dire les gens qui sont à peu près
éduqués qui sont à peu près implantés
localement qui ont les moyens de mener
une campagne et on voit qu'ils aient
moore qui allait parler à versailles en
attendant en train de draguer cet
électorat-là et marine le pen fait aussi
la même chose en allant chercher des
personnes comme charles millon ancien
ministre de la défense qui représente
beaucoup cette droite conservatrice
pendant que eric zemmour lui va chercher
jean frédéric poisson qui représente la
même droite conservatrice mais à une
autre génération il a aussi kim sun
fourvière voilà la saison formellement
va lui rapporter beaucoup d'élus comme
chacun sait voilà enfin bref c'est ça
dont je voulais parler qui va être à mon
avis à suivre de voir comment cette
droite conservatrice va être divisé et
en trois parties va pouvoir apporter
son expertise doit on en reparlera à la
semaine prochaine et en tout cas au
revoir alex il ya bientôt trois c'est la
fin du duel des éditos vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
notre site rt france point tv et en
podcast sur toutes les plateformes vous
pouvez également réagir dans les
commentaires et sur les réseaux sociaux
via le hashtag ldd eux à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau duel des
éditos
[Musique]